[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur wahl des militär
des jahres ich freue mich sehr dass sie
wieder mit dabei sind wir zeichnen
angehörige des österreichischen
bundesheeres aus die besonderes
geleistet haben und zwar in den
kategorien
rekrut des jahres zivildienst oder des
jahres einheit des jahres und soldat des
jahres außerdem werden zwei special
awards vergeben
diesmal zeichnen wir in der kategorie
soldaten des jahres aus zu beginn sehen
sie den nominierten in alphabetischer
reihenfolge
[Musik]
markus schupp die übernimmt im mai 20 20
mit 270 man den kompletten betrieb und
post verteilerzentrum hagen druck im
februar dieses jahres wird er rund um
die uhr anti gen tests an den
landesgrenzen in salzburg und vorarlberg
durch klaus stockinger ist der
maßgebliche motor beim aufbau des
informations moduls miliz durch seine
konsequente arbeitsweise wird das
strategische informations und führungs
element fixer bestandteil in der
struktur des verteidigungsministeriums
richard weyringer der ehemalige jacken
an der soldat zeichnet sich durch ein
außergewöhnliches engagement bei der
betreuung von menschen aus der priester
notdienst der zivil spitäler macht ihn
zu einem besonderen in der glied zur
zivilbevölkerung
[Musik]
und wer jetzt soldat des jahres wird das
weiß verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner
es ist mir eine ganz besondere freude
heute den award für den soldat des
jahres bekannt zu geben unsere
bediensteten die erbringen jedes jahr
herausragende leistungen und viele von
ihnen würden diesen award verdienen doch
es ist so wie im sport es kann nur einen
sieger geben
unser gewinner hat nicht nur eine
hervorragende reputation auf seiner
dienststelle und langjährige
auslandseinsatz erfahrung musste auch im
zuge der coop 19 pandemie mit seiner
kompanie mehrmals außergewöhnliches
leisten ich spreche hier von hauptmann
markus schütz vom versorgungs regiment
einst seine vorausschauen dass eine
selbstständige arbeitsweise im sinne des
kommandanten macht ihn zu einem fachlich
hochqualifizierten mitarbeiter dies
stellte er auch im zuge verschiedenster
kurzfristig zu leistender cupid
assistenzeinsätze unter beweis bei der
übernahme des post verteilungszentrum
sind für 15 tage musste er mit seiner
kompanie rund 100000 pakete pro tag zur
auslieferung bringen beim
assistenzeinsatz in tirol im februar
dieses jahres kann man wieder mit
kompanie starken kräften zum einsatz
beim antigen testeinsatz an den
landesgrenzen zu salzburg und vorarlberg
muss innerhalb von zwei tagen 60
soldaten rekrutiert werden um den
auftrag mit vier -test bussen rund um
die uhr durchführen zu können je mehr
brillen erfolgte dann die unterstützung
das militärkommando steiermark bei der
auslieferung von rund einer billion
testkits hauptmann schotte hat das
verantwortliche kompaniekommandant all
diese herausforderungen mit bravour
erledigt und es waren zusätzliche
aufgaben denn hat man schritte zeichnete
in dieser fordernden zeit auch für die
kader anwärter ausbildung 1 und die
durchführung der basis ausbildung der
rekruten im regiment verantwortlich
durch sein hohes maß an
verantwortungsbewusstsein durch seine
loyalität um seine führungsfähigkeit
verbunden mit seiner akzeptanz beim
kader konnten alle aufträge zur vollsten
zufriedenheit der vorgesetzten
durchgeführt werden herr hauptmann ich
darf ihnen sehr herzlich zum gewinn des
awards soldat des jahres gratulieren und
ihnen viel soldatenglück bei ihrem
derzeitigen auslandseinsatz in bosnien
herzegowina wünschen
hört man immer rechnen die auszeichnung
soldat des jahres ich bin sehr stolz auf
sie dankeschön dankeschön
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zum start des jahres 20 21
die aus bernau der steiermark geboren am
18 juni 1987 ein soldat des jahres ohne
besondere charakter eigenschaften also
für mich natürlich so wie ich das
bezeichnen finde ich habe ich keine
speziellen charaktereigenschaften weil
es für mich selbstverständlich ist aber
für mich zählt natürlich
also das pflichtbewusstsein
kameradschaft ehrlichkeit aufrichtigkeit
die auftrags erfüllung und deswegen bin
ich auch soldat geworden oder dessen bin
ich auch offizier geworden weil ich
menschen führen möchte weil mir sehr am
herzen liegt wie auch sehr gefällt und
deswegen glaube einfach für mich ist es
zwar normal aber offen sich dieses etwas
mehr als normal und deswegen ist es her
dass das hervorgehoben wird da lässt
sich eine ausgeprägte bescheidenheit
schon erkennen und dazu gesellt sich
noch eine gesunde portion ehrgeiz das
heißt aber ich bin nicht der klassische
typ der sich jetzt überlegt was bin ich
in fünf jahren was erzählen wo möchte
von 40 jahren sein für mich zählt das
aktuelle dann möchte ich immer mein
bestes geben aber ich möchte mir für die
zukunft alles offen lassen und ich finde
man sollte im leben nie etwas
ausschließen weil man nicht weiß wie es
tatsächlich kommt und so kommt es dass
sie sich zurzeit bereits zum vierten mal
im auslandseinsatz befindet diesmal in
bosnien herzegowina diese oft sehr
fordernden einsätze meister markus ohne
wenn und aber mit ein grund dafür ist
der rückhalt vor allem von meiner
freundin und auch von meiner familie
sehr wichtig der rückhalt ist eigentlich
das was mir die kraft gibt
die kurzfristigen anstrengungen des
dienstes und so weiter wirklich gut zu
bewältigen und stress abzubauen seien
sprichwörtliche fels in der brandung ist
seine lebensgefährtin wir meistern das
gemeinsam und sie weiß auch dass dann
die zeiten wieder kommen wollt dann auch
wieder etwas mehr zu hause bin und also
sie ist da wirklich da kann ich mich zu
1000 prozent auf sie verlassen zu 1000
prozent können sich auch seine kameraden
darauf verlassen dass ihr trotz der
auszeichnung der bleibt der ist also für
mich ist das ein zeigen dass ich bisher
zumindest vieles richtig gemacht habe
vor allem in meiner funktion als als
kommandant für mich ist es aber auch
natürlich der klassische militärische
auftrag auch zu sagen okay bis hierhin
hat es super gepasst das heißt aber
jetzt nicht nachlassen sondern in dieser
bauart sozusagen weiterzumachen und das
ist schon ein ansporn für mich auch zu
sagen bisher alles richtig gemacht aber
in zukunft wartet noch viel arbeit und
viele aufträge wie möglich natürlich
auch ehrgeizig pflichtbewusst und
ordnungsgemäß erledigen und wer wenn
nicht er weiß ganz genau wie man soldat
des jahres wird eigentlich ist das gar
nicht so schwer ein zeuge versuchen
jeden tag das beste von sich selbst zu
geben
authentisch zu bleiben um die wie gesagt
nicht darauf zu warten sondern meiner
meinung ist es so dass sich dass sich
leistung ehrgeiz ehrlichkeit in jeder
gesellschaft in jeder zeit immer
durchsetzt und das dann von selbst
andere leute darauf aufmerksam werden
und sehen okay der oder diejenige gibt
wirklich das beste und dass man so unter
anführungszeichen vielleicht auch diese
nominierung zur auszeichnung erhält aber
nicht insbesondere auf diese
auszeichnung hin arbeiten sollte sondern
einfach sein bestes jeden tag geben
wir alle gratulieren herrn hauptmann
markus schuth ist sehr herzlich zu
dieser auszeichnung zum soldat des
jahres das meine damen und herren war
die letzte ausgabe da war das militär
des jahres und ich hoffe dass sie auch
nächstes jahr wieder mit dabei sind bis
dahin machen sie es gut und bleiben sie
gesund
[Musik]